[Music]
football is a sport filled with
high-profile skilled positions like
quarterback and receiver long snapper
doesn't quite make the list but snapping
a football through your legs as far as
15 feet directly into another player's
hands in less than a second takes
precision perhaps military precision
that is certainly the case for Joe
Cardona in June the Patriots long
snapper in the second year of a
four-year $4,000,000 NFL deal was
promoted to lieutenant in the US Navy
ensuring another season of double duty
one weekend a month and at least two
weeks a year
Joe Cardona is like any other member of
the Naval Reserves but come Sunday's
every fall
lieutenant Cardona becomes a different
kind of patriot what does that meant to
you to be able to represent the Navy in
the NFL but also represent the NFL in
the Navy I think it's a tremendous
opportunity that you know the reserves
has really granted me and my ultimate
goals to really bring back knowledge
that I've gained here and and put it
back into the service the idea of
service to country was instilled in
Cardona at an early age having grown up
the son of a sailor but his first love
was football I played football as long
as I can remember I was just talking to
my mom the other day and I'd mentioned I
don't know the last time I had a fall
without football and it's like well you
never had a fall without football but
cardona's father didn't think his under
sized son would make his high school
team so in military like fashion they
would arrive early at practice and
focused on drills that would arm Cardona
with an array of skills so you'd have me
kick the ball upon it
snap it you know anything that I could
do to find to get better right and that
that really stuck his passion for the
military also developed with Marine
Corps Air Station Miramar about 20 miles
from cardona's home I mean you grew up
near Miramar and you see you see jets
flying over there's nothing cooler than
that I wanted to fly I wanted that
experience
miramar served as the inspiration for
the movie Top Gun which in turn became
inspiration for cardona's dad Joey this
is Ghost Rider requesting a flyby every
time I ask for something I was a little
bit out of the ordinary my dad would
give me the old that's a negative
ghostrider the pattern is full I wasn't
trying to buzz at our anything with that
but he'd always give me that line as if
Hollywood scripted it Cardona was able
to combine his two passions when it came
time for college he'd filled out and
grown enough to be recruited by the u.s.
Naval Academy to play football while his
sixth resize would keep Cardona from the
cockpit it became his advantage as a
long snapper for your starter for the
Midshipmen the length of my torso
essentially disqualified me from flying
in every platform that I wanted to you
know and that's when I really had to
take a take a moment and reassess what I
wanted to do and so I had to give up my
dream of flying jets and you know being
maverick cookies in 2015 Cardona became
just the fourth long snapper ever
drafted in the NFL but there was still
the issue of his military service which
at the time meant active duty for all
service Academy graduates there was a
point where I didn't know whether or not
I'd actually be able to play in the NFL
or whether I'd have to you know go
active duty and and be in that role that
I'd prepared for Cardona would spend his
rookie season fulfilling his service
obligations 60 miles away from the
Patriots home in Newport Rhode Island
working for the Navy at night and one
full day a week at the Naval Academy of
preparatory school I'd to spend my leave
to go to training camp and being a
rookie an NFL is hard enough but I was
also trying to find my bearings as a
junior officer fortunately you know if
you do your job on the military side and
you're taking care of everything you
need to with your command you know we
don't care what you do with your free
time go ahead play football for this
yeah exactly
your full-time job is being in the Navy
but your full-time job is a rookie with
the New England Patriots does that sound
at all crazy to you
it absolutely sounds crazy to me even
looking back
I can't even imagine doing that again I
think I was so ingrained with with those
core values of the Naval Academy you
know it's like honor courage and
commitment you know and having to uphold
those his dedication hasn't been lost on
his teammates including kicker Stephen
Gostkowski we play 16 games and we're
here all day every day and talk about
football and work out for football and
do training for football and you know he
would come in and practice enough to go
work another job and put things into
perspective after two Super Bowl titles
and a switch from active to reserve duty
Cardona remains as steadfast in his
commitment to both the military and the
NFL in June his military promotion
ceremony was held on the same day as the
Patriots got their new Super Bowl rings
there was just a really special thing
there to see you know guys like Brady
and Edelman go up to them and hug them
and tell them thank you for your service
when you look at where you are right now
early in your NFL career early in your
military career how long can you keep
doing both that is a great question I
don't know how long but I'm going to
continue to do the best I can as long as
they you know let me fulfill either role
you know Cardona talks about this idea
the ideals behind both the military and
the Patriots and those ideals that are
instilled in him and it was both
organizations really having some
flexibility to allow him to do this as
well I have just one question isn't he
tired he seemed as he thought back about
it how tired he was now with the
reserves obviously it frees up more time
for him but there other guys who are
doing this right now the Vikings also
have a long snapper who came out of the
Air Force the army on the Eagles squad
the Steelers have someone there about a
handful of guys right now from service
academies that are playing he might be
tired but it's working for him yeah
there's no time to get into trouble
there's no time to focus on anything
else